thanks for that introduction it's really
nice to be doing a book talk right here
in Palo Alto I don't live in Palo Alto
anymore but lived in Palo Alto for eight
years and moved to Santa Cruz a little
over a year ago and really loved living
in Palo Alto for a lot of different
reasons and I think one of the things
that's most fascinating to me about this
particular area is that it's just such a
a hotbed of entrepreneurial activity and
technological innovation and for a while
when I lived in Palo Alto I live
downtown on on Addison and Addison
Avenue and lived across the street from
the famous garage where HP had its
humble beginnings and for the longest
time couldn't understand why people
would crowd around the garage and look
at it and one day I finally walked over
there to see what was going on and read
the plaque and realized what it was all
about but you know Palo Alto has been at
the center of a variety of different
technology revolutions the computer
revolution is certainly one of those in
the internet revolution is another one
before I get started talking a little
bit about calm divas and why I wrote the
book I'm curious to see if anyone here
works it a start-up okay several people
and is anyone does anyone here consider
themselves an entrepreneur is anyone
here a business owner so few more people
cool well one of the reasons that i
wrote calm divas is that i love hearing
stories from entrepreneurs i love
hearing where they get that initial
flash of a business idea and one of the
things that I've learned after
interviewing all of these women
entrepreneurs is that business ideas
come from all different kinds of places
and out of all different types of
experiences so that it's been very very
interesting to hear those stories and I
think for me one of the best parts about
writing this book was having a really
solid excuse to get out there and get
time with these women
and and hear their stories find out
about the challenges they were facing
find out about what was going on in
their lives at the time that they
started their businesses and one of the
things that I realized pretty soon after
I got into the research for the book was
that women have gravitated toward the
net and I want to back up for a second
because at the time that I got the idea
for this book I was working at Adobe on
the e-business team there and one of the
things that I noticed was that a there
were a lot of women on the internet team
there and that be when women co-workers
left they are often weren't leaving to
go off to another job in another company
a lot of the time they were leaving to
go start a business of their own and in
a lot of instances it was an internet
businesses an internet business and
prior to working at Adobe ID worked it
into it on the quick and calm team and
there are actually a couple of folks
here tonight from the quick and calm
team and there I noticed something
similar a lot of women working on the
internet team and also the same trend
when women left in several instances
they would leave to go start an internet
business of their own and I think part
of why this stuck out in my mind is that
I'd also spend some time working in the
semiconductor industry and there there
were totally different gender
demographics not a lot of women working
in the semiconductor industry so at the
same time that I was thinking about this
I also started reading more books about
entrepreneurial activity and reading
books about things that investors are
doing in the technology arena and
started to notice that for the most part
these books were focusing on men I'm
thinking of books like e boys which
tells the story of the venture
capitalists at benchmark books like the
silicon boys in their Valley of dreams
looks like the new new thing which
profiles Jim Clark there's aol.com there
are a lot of these books out there and
given what I was experiencing in the
workplace I started to feel like there
was a piece of the story that hadn't
been written yet and decided that I
would take some time away from my job at
Adobe to try and write this book and
calm divas
the result of that when when I first dug
into some of the kind of numbers
research for the book I came across some
very interesting statistics that venture
one puts out and the statistics show
that that internet startups have a
higher percentage of women CEOs and a
higher percentage of women in top
management positions than other types of
startup companies and on each of your
chairs there is a handout if you look at
the second page there's a graph that
shows this trend that you know just
shows the number of women CEOs and women
in management positions that internet
startups versus non internet startups so
for me this kind of confirmed what I had
an intuitive sense about from what I'd
seen going on in the workplace so I
started to wonder about why this is why
was this happening and after giving it
some thought and talking to a lot of
people about it came up with four
reasons that I think helped to explain
this trend one certainly is the Internet
boom of the late 90s with the Internet
boom there was so much capital there was
a glut of capital available to
entrepreneurs and this opened up
opportunities for entrepreneurs that
didn't fit the typical mold it opened up
new opportunities for women
entrepreneurs it certainly opened up
opportunities for young entrepreneurs
and for first-time entrepreneurs so
that's I think one of the things that is
going on that explains this trend I
think another thing is that Internet
companies haven't been particularly tied
to traditional ways of working or
entrenched power structures for those of
you who raised your hand and said that
you do work at internet companies you've
probably seen that in some cases these
companies are not very bureaucratic or
hierarchical some of them are even
pretty anti bureaucratic and part of
what that enables is quick
decision-making when decision-making is
kind of farmed out to everyone within a
company and so I think this openness in
some ways has
made Internet companies hold the promise
for entrepreneurs including women
entrepreneurs and they've held the
promise and also the potential for
possibly starting a business on your own
terms and I think that that's been
particularly attractive to women I think
also a third thing that has contributed
to this trend is that with the rise of
the Internet there's been a rise in
organizations that are dedicated to
advancing women entrepreneurs on one of
these that has made a tremendous impact
as the forum for women entrepreneurs and
the forum for women entrepreneurs
started in in 94 and their main office
is in san francisco and the FWE holds an
event which they held last year for the
first time and it's called springboard
2000 and at this event women
entrepreneurs have the opportunity to do
elevator pitches to an auditorium full
of venture capitalists and this event
alone has made a tremendous impact in a
tremendous difference through this event
last year women entrepreneurs raised
more than 260 million dollars in funding
for their companies and Thursday of last
week I went to springboard 2001 it was
held at Oracle in redwood shores and it
was just for me you know so inspiring to
see twenty four different women get up
there and pitch their businesses for 15
minutes each some really great business
ideas some really interesting
entrepreneurs and I hope that they'll be
just as successful this year even in
this market as the entrepreneurs were
last year at springboard 2000 and
raising their funding and I think a
fourth reason for the trend is that
within the last few years and really
coinciding also with the rise of the
Internet we've seen new venture funds
opening up that are specifically
targeting women entrepreneurs there's
one of these located right here in Palo
Alto called new Vista capital it focuses
on women and minority lead companies
there's also Isabella capital there are
there are a number of these women's
growth capital
is another one there are also more women
who have become venture capitalists
themselves and this is something that's
pretty new the venture capital arena
historically and even today has been
very male-dominated and things are
getting better in you know inch by inch
it's getting better today about actually
a little bit less than five percent of
venture capitalists are women but that
in and of itself is making a difference
partly because of the way the venture
capital industry works if an
entrepreneur wants to get some face time
with a venture capitalist they most of
the time need to be referred by someone
who has one degree or two degrees of
separation from from that VC and women
just haven't been as plugged into that
Network as men have been so the
emergence of new funds targeting women
more women vc's all of these things
combined I think are part of the things
that explain that trend that you see in
that graph about more women in
leadership roles in Internet companies
now one thing that really stuck in my
mind even though the funding situation
has gotten much better for women
entrepreneurs when I was interviewing
the many entrepreneurs that I did 4.com
divas one I did hear a couple of stories
about things that entrepreneurs
experienced in capital raising that
their male counterparts wouldn't have
experienced just to give you a Down Paul
one of the entrepreneurs her name's
Felicia lindau and she's the founder of
a really cool company called sparks calm
and sparks calm actually I'm curious as
anyone heard of sparks calm a couple of
people so sparks calm is a company that
sells paper greeting cards online and
now in and of itself that might not
sound particularly interesting but the
really cool thing about it is they'll
actually sign seal and deliver the cards
for you it's very convenient to use and
I've been hooked on it I'm kind of
ashamed to say that I yes I do sometimes
sent out cars and it's not really my
signature in the car
but anyway Felicia was pitching her
business to a venture capital firm that
will go unnamed and they loved the
business idea they thought it was great
they wanted to invest but they they had
one condition in their condition was
that she get a front man for her
business they wanted a male CEO for the
company and and they went on to fax
resumes over to Felicia of potential
front men that they thought would be
good for her business and naturally she
ended up going with a different venture
capital firm another story along the
same lines that I heard was from vaani
Cola and vaani is a very successful
entrepreneur she started a company
called right works which she since sold
a majority stake in the company to
internet Capital Group at a valuation of
over a billion dollars and when she was
initially pitching her business idea to
some VCS she was in the unique position
of being pregnant at the time and kind
of seeing the reactions of the venture
capitalists that she was pitching to and
more than one VC said to her that they
just weren't comfortable investing in a
pregnant entrepreneur that they felt
that it was too great an investment risk
and so you know things like these have
happened things like this happen they're
continuing to happen it's unfortunate
but the upside is that the funding arena
for women has improved substantially
over the past few years
when I first started writing the book I
you know I was kind of scratching my
head how do I get started writing this
book and I ended up putting email out to
a variety of different women in
technology mailing lists saying that I
was looking for women founded Internet
companies and I thought that you know
maybe I'd come across 40 or 50 that
would be good candidates for the book
and then I choose 20 from from that and
I was so pleasantly surprised because my
email box was literally jammed with
email messages for more than 200 women
who wanted to tell me about their
internet business and it was just so
neat to see that there was that level of
entrepreneurial activity happening out
there by women and since then I've and
looking at numbers and statistics a
little bit more there is a statistic
that shows that women are starting
businesses at a rate twice that of the
national average so a lot of
entrepreneurial activity by women
happening these days and let's see here
with with the book how he ended up
structuring it is that each chapter
focuses on a different entrepreneur and
her business and I picked the
entrepreneurs with an eye to variety i
was looking for entrepreneurs with very
different backgrounds so some of these
women come from working-class family
some come from wealthy families some
have mba summer technologists a lot of
different types of backgrounds two of
the companies are located outside of the
united states ones in sao paulo and ones
in tokyo and i also picked businesses
that are in very different market
segments so just a lot of variety and
the types of businesses and i want to
tell you a little bit about a couple of
the entrepreneurs in the book and
Eugenie de serio is one of them and
she's the founder of a company called
astronaut and at the time that she got
her business idea she was she was kind
of down on her luck she had been through
a bad breakup she was a single mom she
was unemployed she lost her job and she
kind of been forced because of financial
reasons to move back in with her mom and
dad so she was living at home and trying
to figure out what she would do next and
she had a long-standing passion which
was astrology and so she started writing
horoscopes and she decided that she
start publishing these things online and
at that time it was back in 1994 before
anyone was putting horoscopes on the
internet and AOL was making small
investments in content companies they
felt had some promise and they
discovered Eugenie de serio and the
horoscopes that she was putting online
and gave her some seed funding she
started publishing these horoscopes on
AOL and I mean now we all know that
horoscopes ended up taking off on the
web the same way that they become a
fixture in newspapers and magazines and
each of the entrepreneurs in the book
gives their gives three pieces of advice
for other entrepreneurs and I want to
read to you Eugenie's three pieces of
advice actually online she goes by
jeanne easy that's her her handle that
she uses online so she says focus locate
a niche the
needs to be filled and create a focus
remain disciplined and committed to your
mission don't let anyone or anything let
you waver she says endure confront
obstacles as opportunities for problem
solving and for constantly pushing
yourself to new levels follow your own
gut instincts over anyone elses she said
says act timing is everything
procrastination is very damaging in this
type of fast-moving industry if you
snooze you lose and I think that last
point if you snooze you lose is such an
important one especially in technology
you might have a great product but if it
comes out six months too early or six
months too late it's just not going to
fly it'll-it'll miss the opportunity so
timing is extremely important another
one of the entrepreneurs in the book is
Susan Strasburg and she's the CEO of
edgar online and the co-founder of that
company and she started it with her
husband in a room above their garage in
Connecticut and the part I love about
her story is that she started the
company when she was a grandmother of
five and which is you know unusual with
Internet companies you're always hearing
about these 20-something who start an
internet company but she was a
grandmother and edgar online has done
great it's one of the most popular
financial websites out there and that's
who hears heard of edgar online okay a
lot of people and I'm curious how do you
how do you use that girl online you
haven't used it uh-huh
well if the site publishes sec filings
so yeah so so when I uh-huh uh-huh so
one of the other people who raises hand
you raised your hand how do you use the
site
uh-huh uh-huh so for in so for analyzing
accompanies as a potential investment
uh-huh cool yeah there's people use that
site in all different kinds of ways some
people will use it to do competitive
research if if there's a company that's
very closely similar to them and to say
market space they'll go and read the
company's SEC filings because there's a
lot of information about company's
strategy in those documents so anyway
want to read to you Susan Strasburg
three pieces of advice for entrepreneurs
she says take the risk it's never too
late to try something new my husband and
I are living proof of this she says hire
smart people the success of your company
rests on the quality of your team she
says execute execute execute execution
is ninety-nine percent of the game stay
focused and stick to your idea don't let
other people throw you off course and
then I'm going to tell you one more
story about a third entrepreneur in the
book and her name is Doreen shahnaz and
she started a company called one nest
and Doreen grew up in Bangladesh and was
educated in the United States and after
she finished school she moved back to
Bangladesh and started working for
Grameen Bank which is a pretty
progressive revolutionary bank that
makes micro loans for rural impoverished
women so that they can start small scale
enterprises and Durin's job was to trek
out to these villages and make loans to
women that had applied for them and then
follow up with them to see how they were
doing with their businesses and these
are you know these are very modest
enterprises the loans were you know
maybe twenty thirty forty dollars the
women would use the money to perhaps by
a loom and thread to we fabric or to buy
a pottery wheel to make pottery and in
seeing how they progressed one of the
things that Doreen discovered was that
they had what
would be called I guess here in Silicon
Valley it would be called a channel
distribution problem in that they were
creating all these wonderful handicrafts
but they were having difficulty getting
them into the marketplace because in
Bangladesh women don't travel with the
same freedom that they do and certainly
in a country like the United States
Bangladesh is predominantly a Muslim
culture and women stay pretty close to
where they live so these women were
needing to persuade a husband and uncle
a brother to take goods to market for
them and so it was this experience in
der means life that many years later was
her inspiration to start one nest and
what this company does is it enables
artisans around the world to sell their
goods on a wholesale basis to global
markets using the internet so pretty
pretty inspiring entrepreneur with a
neat story and I want to read her three
lessons for entrepreneurs to you as well
she says don't start a business unless
you feel passionately about it with your
heart and soul your motivation needs to
be something other than making money
because there isn't enough money to
compensate you for the stress of
launching a net startup she says sell
sell sell as a founder you're the chief
evangelist ninety percent of your job is
to sell the company its ideas goals and
potential not only to investors but also
to staffers and she says and this is
something that that's really important
she says get the blessing of your spouse
or significant other before you plunge
in without it moving forward will be
difficult because a net venture is
all-consuming so oh and actually there
was earlier another piece of advice that
I wanted to tell you it's not listed in
her three pieces of advice but I heard
one of the wackiest weirdest pieces of
entrepreneurial advice from from Eugenie
de serio
and it's something that I get guess you
would really only hear from an
entrepreneur who was into astrology she
says don't find deals when Mercury's in
retrograde she's convinced that if you
sign a deal during a Mercury retrograde
that the deal will fail so one of the
things that kind of took me by surprise
after interviewing all of these women
and hearing their stories when I was
going through the notes I had and
listening to the interview tapes I had I
realized that there were a few traits
that were pretty consistent across the
board and part of the reason that that
surprised me was that I had picked them
especially because they were very
different from each other so I wasn't
expecting there to be that consistency
and I kind of come to think of these
traits as prototypical entrepreneurial
traits and the first one of these is
passion all of the women I talked with
were extremely passionate about their
business idea they're the kind of people
who if they get an idea they feel
compelled to pursue it they feel
compelled to turn it into something real
they're also very persistent people if
they encounter an obstacle if they fall
down they stand right back up and if
they fall down again they stand back
again and they do this over and over and
over again and you know part part of
being successful is failing and part of
being successful is taking risks and
without doing that you don't open up the
possibility for having successes in life
so these women really put themselves out
there on the line and and they see what
happens another trait that they all
shared with optimism all extreme
optimists they look on the bright side
they think positively another thing is
effective communication all of these
women are very good communicators and
the last trade in common I think kind of
really goes hand-in-hand with effective
communication they're very energetic
they have just a lot of enthusiasm and
energy and why I think these two things
go hand in hand especially for an
entrepreneur is that when you're
starting out a company you're really
starting
with nothing I mean you don't you don't
have anything there's no people there's
no money and you just have your idea and
your enthusiasm for it and so the
ability to communicate out your vision
for the business and to express your
energy and enthusiasm for it it's really
that that ends up being compelling to
prospective employees to prospective
partners to prospective investors so
I've kind of come to think of these five
traits as somewhat of a litmus test for
the entrepreneurial personality type one
thing too that I think is very important
to consider when starting a company and
it's something that I heard about time
and time again from these women is the
impact that it will have on your
personal life and Nancy Evans who's a
co-founder of I village has a quote in
here that kind of speaks to this topic
that will read to you she says starting
a business is a commitment of time and
energy beyond anything you've ever done
you're going to be tired you're going to
lose touch with friends and niceties to
yourself like those bubble baths you're
supposed to take will fall to the
wayside but if you're realizing a dream
it's worth it and I think that that's so
true i mean i heard a lot of stories of
you know from these entrepreneurs they
love what they're doing they're very
into the businesses that they're working
on creating but a lot of pain around not
being able to spend as much time with
their children as they'd like to or
their their husbands or significant
others and so that's something that is
certainly a challenge in has actually
led me to my next book idea and for my
next book I'm planning on writing about
work-life balance issues for people in
high tech having experienced personally
and then discovered through all these
conversations with other people that it
is such a pain point for four people one
more thing I wanted to comment on is all
of the all of the hype that we're seeing
right now about the internet being dead
all of the doom and gloom that's out
they're in the press right now all of
the dot bombs stories I mean you can't
open up any newspaper or magazine
without reading this stuff and I think
you know the media really tends to
overhype when the Nasdaq was at 5,000
life was great you know and life was
great and the media reflected this I
mean they really there was just this
level of enthusiasm in the media that
was overdone and I think now we're
seeing that you know in in Reverse or
the pendulums completely swung to the
other side you know the sky is falling
the Internet's dying etc etc and I think
that regardless of what the market is
doing it at any given moment it's
certainly true that the Internet is one
of the biggest technological revolutions
that we will see in our lifetime it's
changed the way that we do business it's
changed the way that we communicate with
each other and it's certainly changed
the way that we live our daily lives
especially in a place here like right in
the midst of Silicon Valley it's really
changed our lives and just to give a
little bit of data that gives some
perspective on the situation in the last
three quarters of 2000 venture capital
funding has decreased but one thing that
is interesting is that four year 2000 as
a whole venture capital investments were
eighty percent higher than what they
were in 1999 another interesting fact is
that in the fourth quarter of two
thousand eighty percent of venture
capital was going to internet companies
now this is lower than what it's been
before but eighty percent of all venture
capitals still a tremendous amount of
money being invested in Internet
companies one of the kind of fun things
about writing a book that i've
discovered is that a couple of weeks
after the books been out and people have
seen it and started to read it is you
start to get these kind of random emails
from people who want to ask you a
question or say something to you and I
got one about three weeks ago that
really made my day and I wanted to read
it to you see if I can find it here I
know it's here and my stack of papers
here it is it says hi my name is Ashley
and I'm thinking of starting an Internet
company either a web design company or a
company that sells clipart on CD ROMs
what should I consider in making the
decision I'm excellent with websites
HTML and animated banner design now
here's the punch line she goes on to say
I'm 12 will this be a problem i've heard
there are some 13 and over laws thanks
Ashley well I got this email and I
thought that was so cool i thought you
know any girl like Ashley she's going to
go really far in life and it really made
me think that you know the more that we
can do to encourage girls to feel at
home in the technology arena the more
that we can encourage girls to feel at
home in the business world the better
off we're all going to be in the
handouts you have toward the back it's I
think it's the third to last page there
are a list of resources there for
entrepreneurs and I picked out a few of
the resources from dot com divas in the
book there is a resource appendix that
lists a lot of different types of
resources funding sources for
entrepreneurs especially for women
entrepreneurs organizations that help
women entrepreneurs websites etc there's
a lot of good stuff in there but for
those of you who don't buy the book you
at least get the cliff note version
there in the handout and one of these
sources that I just want to mention
because it is a very useful one is
venturewire and at venturewire you can
subscribe to an email list it's free and
it gives a daily email message that
summarizes what's happening in the
funding community it lists what
businesses that have gotten funded how
much money they've raised and also gives
information
on merger and acquisition activity and
if you're thinking of starting a
business and you have a variety of
different business ideas that you're
looking at it can be a good way to gauge
what segments of the market are hot
what's getting funded at any given
moment so it can be very useful in that
regard also listed there are some of the
venture funds for women entrepreneurs
that I mentioned earlier and then on the
next page there are some networking
resources that are great ones for
entrepreneurs and for Women in
Technology web girls women in technology
international the forum for women
entrepreneurs which I mentioned grace
net Churchill club one of the wonderful
things about living here where you do is
there is such an abundance of these
organizations and networking
opportunities to you know both advance
your career or help you build a business
whatever it might be and one of the
things that I heard a lot when I was
interviewing women entrepreneurs 4.com
divas is that entrepreneurs can feel
isolated they can feel lonely and many
of the women expressed a desire to have
a place where they could connect with
other women entrepreneurs so starting
next month I'm going to be co
facilitating two workshops one is for
women entrepreneurs and the other is
targeted toward towards women in
technology and women executives and
they're both leadership workshops and
I'm co facilitating them with Cynthia
Scott who is a management consultant and
a coach and if you're interested in that
I've got some Flyers up here on the
table about that and you can come pick
one up and that was everything that I
had prepared so if anyone has a question
to ask I'd be happy to answer any
questions
what was the most difficult part of
writing this book for you
for me it was having to write fast
because I'm not a fast writer and there
was a hard deadline or at least I
believed the deadline was hard I think
you know in retrospect I've learned that
I probably could have said oh I can't
make the deadline and the publisher
would have moved it for me but you know
that the pace that I had to keep up with
was was tight I wrote the book in a
little over five months and so you know
it meant every day I was sitting at the
computer pretty much all day long
researching and writing when I wasn't
out interviewing people so I think just
the pace that I had to maintain to
finish it by the due date that I had was
one of the most difficult parts
what did I tell Ashley well I told
Ashley that regardless of which business
idea she pursued that you know she was
she was gonna learn a lot and just also
to told her that if she's thinking this
way already at age 12 that she's going
to have so many great experiences in
life and that it's such a pleasure to
get an email like that and then I told
her some practical things like that she
probably should talk to her parents
about it and but that she might want to
check out her local chapter score and
things like that so
any more questions yeah the most
inspiring
a bit of information you back from these
something that really inspired you to
start your own company
huh let's see you know I don't know if
there was one you know kind of one
little nugget of information that i
found most inspirational I think what
for me was most inspirational was the
abundance of entrepreneurial activity
out there by women and having the
opportunity to write about the stories
of all different types of women starting
businesses and that for me was was most
inspiring and also seeing that these are
not women who are starting small
home-based businesses these are women
who are raising venture capital and
trying to build you know billion dollar
businesses so that that to me was also
very inspiring because a lot of people
when they think women run business they
think small business they think
home-based business and so I wanted to
tell a very different story from that
about women going out there with big
ambitions trying to start very big
companies
to begin with you know it was it was
really the combination of work having
worked at Adobe having worked it into it
having seen how many women were working
in the internet space and having a sense
that these women were going out some of
them were going out and starting
companies of their own and then the
disjunction between that and walking
into a bookstore and seeing a big
display with a boys all over it or a big
display with the silicon boys in their
Valley of dreams all over it I wanted a
book to be out there that would be a
book that I would want to read that
would be a book that would draw John me
in and give me role models and give me
examples that I could relate to in a way
that that would be easier for me than
say relating to to the e boys look oh I
didn't know what to do I didn't know
what to do i was completely clueless and
actually what i did was i did a search
on amazon and i found a book called how
to write a book proposal and i followed
the instructions i wrote the book
proposal and in retrospective realized
that it's writing a book proposals very
much like writing a business plan you
have a few pages about what the
company's about and then you have a lot
of pages about how it's going to be
marketable and you know how it's going
to make money and this kind of thing so
I wrote the book proposal and then got
got very lucky i sent it off to
mcgraw-hill and got a call back and they
said that they wanted to do the book and
offered me a contract and then I still
didn't know what to do so I went back to
amazon and i found a book called
negotiating a publishing contract which
i read and that book held my hand
through the contract negotiation and
then I just hunkered down and started
interviewing people and writing and yeah
so that's no that's how
happened so I didn't go about it the
normal way because the normal way is
that people and I've learned more about
what the normal way is now that I've
gone through with me the abnormal ways
that you know usually a writer has an
agent in the agent connects them with
the publisher and the agent takes care
of the contractual issues and that kind
of thing but I'm glad that I did it this
way because I feel like I learned a lot
more doing it this way so any more
questions
the factors that make women gravitate to
the net would also apply to people of
color the openness and other support
structures there are some support
structures I think there are more
support structures for women
entrepreneurs but there are also a lot
of support structures out there for
minority entrepreneurs in fact many of
the venture capital funds that are
targeting women led companies also tart
target minority led companies the fund
here in Palo Alto that i mentioned new
vista capital is a fun for women and
minority entrepreneurs so there are
definitely resources out there i would
love to see more resources out there i
might especially love to see more
african-american women I'm starting
Internet companies I you know kept an
eye open toward diversity in selecting
people 4.com divas and and so I think
that that's kind of the group where it
was pretty clear that there was much
less entrepreneurial activity happening
among african-american women compared to
other minority women so
any more questions thoughts i'm trying
to find role models would you ever
consider writing a children's book like
ashley becomes an entrepreneur ha that's
an interesting idea I'll think about
that one I think about that one there
are some good books out for girls on
starting businesses not a lot of these
books but there are a few that I've seen
and they're really fun books that's a
neat idea cuz I have a very good friend
Catherine d who writes books on self
esteem for girls and maybe I'll pitch
that idea to her and see if she want to
co-author it yeah yeah but i think you
know there's certainly room out there
for books for girls about business and
there's also room for books out there
right now to just on a mentorship I
think in friendship and how friends and
mentors can be instrumental to achieving
successes in life an area that sort of
black and you know um children as
they're growing up girls in particular
learning about business right business
and money right right yeah I mean I I
think that it's shocking that that even
now in many high schools and junior high
schools there's nothing taught about you
know kind of just life skills balancing
a checkbook making a salad you know
these kinds of things aren't taught
taught in schools normally and I know I
mean I I didn't learn how to balance a
checkbook and probably until I started
working it into it right so but there
are some organizations that are helping
to teach girls these skills there is one
that's in San Diego it's called
independent means and they have startup
camps for girls that are kind of like
getting Guy Kawasaki does these boot
camps it's kind of similar to that they
do start up camps for girls and each of
the girls in the camp writes a business
plan and then execute on that business
plan
and a really great program so there are
some of these out there and I think no
the more that can be done in that area
the better any more questions okay well
thanks everybody for coming it's great
to see this crowd here and I see a lot
of familiar faces and that's really nice
too